we are learning more about the
whereabouts of ghilane Maxwell
everyone's looking for her she has kept
a low profile since Geoffrey Epstein's
death meg Oliver's in Manchester by the
sea Massachusetts where neighbors tell
us that ghilane Maxwell has been spotted
meg what are you hearing gal good
morning we have confirmed with property
managers near the mansion that ghilane
Maxwell recently lived in this secluded
mansion going by G or G max just now at
the center of an alleged sexual abuse
ring and the microscope is also on this
town Manchester by the sea is a
picturesque small New England beach town
but now it's in the spotlight for who
may be hiding out here this is the more
than three million dollar mansion where
CBS News has learned British socialite
ghilane Maxwell has recently been stayin
amid accusation she oversaw Geoffrey
Epstein's alleged sex trafficking ring
early Wednesday a civil lawsuit was
filed against Epstein's estate and
Maxwell in it a woman named Jennifer
arose alleged when she was 14 years old
Epstein committed repeated sexual
assault and battery upon her she also
alleged Maxwell participated with an
assisted epstein in maintaining and
protecting his sex trafficking ring
ensuring that approximately three girls
a day were made available to him ghilane
Maxwell has a great deal to be worried
about right now
CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clemens
says now that Jeffrey Epstein is dead
Maxwell may become the focus she has to
be concerned that there may be a
criminal case coming down the pike
Maxwell has mostly avoided the public
eye in recent years but in the past
she's rubbed shoulders with the wealthy
and elite Daily Mail dot-com obtained
these photos reportedly showing tech CEO
Scott Boras and walking Maxwell's dog he
owns the mansion where she may be
staying when we spoke to him he told us
she's certainly not in his house but he
did admit they are friends there are
rumors all over the place about ghilane
Maxwell the truth is we do not know her
status perhaps the government does but
the rest of us don't
the property managers we spoke to said
Boursin and maxwell were a couple and
they saw them running together every
morning maxwell has not been charged
with any crime and recently has denied
any allegations against her Anthony okay
Meg thank you